good morning believe nation today's
message is don't try to avoid mistakes
over to you Mark Zuckerberg so many
things go wrong when you're starting a
company and often I think people ask you
know what mistakes should you avoid
making and you know my answer the
question is don't even bother trying to
avoid mistakes because you're gonna make
tons of mistakes right and the the
important thing is actually learning
quickly from whatever mistakes you make
and not giving up right and I mean there
are things every single year of
Facebook's existence that could have
killed us or made it so that it just
seemed like moving forward and making a
lot of progress just seemed intractable
but you just kind of bounce back and you
learn and nothing is impossible you just
have to kind of keep running through the
walls so I'm not sure I agree completely
with what Mark saying I don't think you
should just head out and not care at all
about mistakes and maybe even seek out
mistakes I don't think that's really the
message he's trying to get out there but
what I think is important is not
dwelling on mistakes and not trying to
play so safe that you don't make any
mistakes I think that's the biggest
thing that a lot of entrepreneurs do
wrong and get wrong they're so worried
about fear and so worried about making
the wrong step and making every little
tiny mistake that they're spending so
much time focusing on the negative and
avoiding the negative instead of
spending your energy you're tying your
resources on the positive and how you
can do something amazing you have to
understand that making mistakes is part
of the process you will make mistakes
it's normal it's natural it's inevitable
and through the mistakes you'll learn
and keep going and make it better the
next time and better the next time
and so it's adopting a mentality that
make mistakes it's okay it's gonna
happen so my question today for you guys
today is do you spend more time trying
to avoid making mistakes or trying to go
out and achieve something big I'm really
curious to find out be honest leave it
in the comments below thank you so much
for watching have an amazing day
to believe and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot a
vinspresso